all right sophie
hi sophie uh where'd you grow up where
are you from i'm from san diego uh i've
lived there my whole life all 21 years
in the same house
and tell me about your family growing up
yeah mom and dad uh yeah my parents are
both high school sweethearts and they're
still together um so i've had a really
good like childhood no no no crazy abuse
running like that no i never had any um
sort of crazy abuse or anything like
that i had i have an older brother who's
four years older
he's in med school and he's uh i'm
really close with him sounds like a
great family yeah i've always had a
great like supportive family i'm very
privileged which i'm very grateful for
um and yeah my parents have always been
really supportive and
i just very i never had to worry about
sort of any um
finances or anything which has been very
i'm very thankful for that i had that
but there are there were a little bit
negatives to the childhood but not
really involving my parents necessarily
i would say the
the abuse of my childhood was the
internet um
of being because if you think about it
like my generation uh is the first and
like only generation to
have only known the internet like i've
all other like generations at least had
some sort of
time when they didn't have social media
the internet but i had it i've had it
ever since i had an iphone when i was
like in seventh grade and i think that
that
was definitely um
led me to where i am today of how just
thinking about how that
affects
your
you know i they should probably do like
a case study on my
i would be the perfect example of how
just the internet can
sort of influence your whole life so how
would you
how would the internet affect your
self-image
well so i think it sort of started um
the
first sort of like i mean a lot of my
childhood i can't really exactly
remember which also makes me think that
there may have been some sort of like
other
trauma type thing that i don't really
exactly know but i
the most like
significant thing uh that i think really
affected me was
there there's this website called omegle
and it's like this
it literally says on the web meet taught
meet strangers or like talk with
strangers and
me and my when i was in seventh grade me
and my friends just thought oh it would
be a cool idea to go and just talk to
strangers and it's like a video chat too
um so you know perfect example of what
bad things can happen on there and um
you know young impressionable
like 12 year old me uh would go on there
and
there'd be a lot of like older guys and
um
a lot of
i would talk to them and you know just
casual like looking back on it
definitely like grooming um
thinking that you know these putting my
these older guys oh they think i'm like
pretty
and when i'm 12 years old and um
eventually they
i started
they would ask me to like take my shirt
off my top off and
my 12 year old self just thought oh this
is like
normal because i think i always
because i've always had a really close
relationship with my dad in particular
and so i think i've always
sort of sought out male validation my
whole life especially because my brother
has always been um he's always had he
graduated with like 4.1 he's been super
smart um always been very like
never like
growing up like never really got in
trouble or anything like that and so i
always sort of saw that and i just
wanted to like make my
like
dad like get his like approval even
though i've always had his approval too
it's just i think i don't know if maybe
i saw like that
give a little bit more attention to my
brother what but i think that that sort
of i've always there's just a common
theme of like male
validation throughout like my whole life
and so i think
that that's how easy i put my trust into
like these older guys on on that i would
like to talk to and
um and i have like one memory in
particular of like i was over at my
friend at the time kimmy's house and
we were on or i was on omegle in her
room and she was like out in the living
room and then
um i was like talking with a guy like
full-on like had me like take my like
top off and stuff just like i think he
was you know like
masturbating or something and she like
walked in
and i like told her like to get out and
then for some reason i like
turned it like i was so like i don't
know if it was like definitely
projecting 12 year old self but i like
told i didn't i told like our other
friends that oh like kimmy was on like
oh my god like taking your shirt off
like talking to people i just like
totally turned it around and so
i i don't know i don't know why like
that memory just like sticks with me for
some reason um
but i think i just i was very like
i don't know if i was ashamed or
something but i just i didn't at the
time i didn't know that it was like
wrong of like oh these older guys i
probably shouldn't be talking to but
it it definitely like
brought into sort of put set up my
mindset going into as i'm going into
like high school at this point of
oh like
put like i can trust like these like i
just want like these guys approval and
and i always like
no matter like throughout my whole life
my looks have always just been very like
important to me because i
i honestly i don't think i'm like good
at anything necessarily i don't think i
have any talents i've never really had
any like particular hobbies so i'm like
okay the only way i'm gonna get
successful in life is if i
buy my looks if i'm pretty um and
so as i'm going into high school i
just sort of i wanted to i mean everyone
just wants to like fit in and stuff in
high school and
um and i had a boyfriend at the time
named cassidy but he was like a very
just like high school you know fake like
not fake relationship but like heist not
a very like significant relationship and
he was like he wanted to he was gonna
break up with me because
his reasoning was because i went on my
phone too much when we hung out um and
i
it was this other guy named raymond
who told me he was they were on water
polo together and he told me that he was
gonna break up with me and raymond was
two years older um
and so and i like knew that cassie was
gonna break up with me i like of course
took initiative of like oh i'm gonna
break up him first and so i did um
and then raymond sort of took that as
like a
just swoop in i guess of like a whole
other and so at this point like i i'm
oh like trusting these guys like okay
like
this guy is giving me attention so like
i'll you know trust him and stuff and
uh that definitely was
the wrong decision because that um
i ended up dating raymond uh well
raymond
uh
groomed me and took my virginity i'm at
14 just thinking that that was like
okay and stuff and i i didn't see
anything wrong with it and
like that he was older and i mean it was
still like you know legal he was like
just two years older and i was 14.
so we ended up dating and
that was
it was a really we dated for two years
and it was a really
abusive relationship this is sort of
when like the abuse started
that would be sort of like a common
theme
the approval of men well just yeah the
approval meant but like him um
like sexually assaulting me like a lot
and but i'm me thinking that like it was
fine because we were dating
um just a lot of like yeah i there was
quite a few times i would sleep over and
he would just like have sex with me even
if i like didn't i would sort of just
not really be into it also i was getting
like
i was getting like a lot of like utis at
this point too and i didn't really like
know what was happening i just felt like
just weird in like my body and stuff
especially because i'm
like 14 15 years old and
um
and
and uh yeah he just there was also
another part of the relationship is that
he
would
always like be
a follow like this would
this was like the one thing that would
make me like so upset is that he
followed like so many like instagram
models and all this stuff and i it made
me like really insecure
of just like oh i wanna because he'd
like comment on their post too
and i would find it because this is when
instagram used to have like the feature
where you could see like
what you could like look at like the
people you follow like the post they
like which they got rid of the feature
now um which is probably good um and i
would like see that and i'd wake up and
i'd just be so like
just like devastated but i
would bring it up to him and then the
minute like i would be like oh like i'm
you know why'd you do like show like
that i was upset
it would just be like turned around of
like
oh well like why don't you trust like
why why are you making like a big deal
out of this like i was just you know
she's just some like random girl like
like and just all the stuff and i would
just be like okay yeah
and sort of go along with it because i
just wanted
to not really
you know i just wanted him as like my
boyfriend and so i started
like
he would because he'd follow like a lot
of like fitness models and so i'd i went
on this like
oh like i'm into fitness and stuff and
my mom actually worked at a gym she
worked at a gym for like 10 years like a
pretty
like nicer gym um so i'd go there to
like work out and i was like starting to
get into like yoga and stuff and
but it never really was just like it was
like i wanted to be like strong and
stuff and i also i
i played water polo throughout high
school um and i was varsity golf captain
um senior year but
i was very so i started getting into
like sports and
just one even though i knew that that
wasn't like who i was or like what i was
into i was always just very like i've
always been very sort of you're doing it
for his approval yeah exactly like that
was not i've never really been into like
you know
and so that that led you into more
social media yeah exactly and so yeah
moving forward we um
we i
finally like broke it off and um we
broke up and that was the first day of
junior year
um and so i
i sort of like i don't know i it's just
weird cause i can't even like think back
like why
i how i ended up like that but
i
i would just sort of let i thought that
oh guys like me because of how i look
and how i how my body is because i was
very um
you know i was very like
i don't want to like come on my like
miner's body but i had like an you know
an appealing body to like high schoolers
and
um so i would just like i would just let
guys like
right after i got out of the
relationship guys just wanted to like
hook up with me and stuff and i just
left let them
um all throughout like the rest of my
high school
career and it it definitely like was a
form of self-harm now looking back on it
like reflecting of just letting guys
like have sex with me and
the one then junior year
um i was over at my friend's house and
we like i think drank a little bit and
we there was like some other people
there that went to a different school
and
i was drunk and then i we were going to
bed
and
um
there was this guy there that
went to a different school that he was
like friends with and he sort of
insisted on
like sleeping with me because there was
or not like he's like actually
physically like sleeping in the same bed
with me and
um and i was like okay and
i even asked him like beforehand of like
oh like are we gonna like hook up or
whatever and he's like no and so i just
went to sleep um
and then
i
just in the middle of the night i just
sort of woke up and
he was having sex with me
and i just froze
because i didn't know like i
like didn't know if it was like actually
happening or not and i sort of just like
went back to sleep after a little bit i
can't even really like
remember exactly
but
he was raping me and
then i just went back to sleep and
i told myself like oh that didn't
actually happen that wasn't real and
then a couple hours later or something i
woke up again in the middle of the night
because i heard him talking
and he was talking to his like grandma
um she i just like remember that
conversation and then i went back to
sleep and then i woke up and
i sort of was just like oh like that was
definitely just like a dream that
happened and then we went out to like
have breakfast in the
downstairs and he started telling them
like oh yeah like my grandma called me
like in the middle of the night
and it just sort of like hit me of like
okay if that happened
then
like that definitely also happened
um and so that
that i've
have been a lot of
i've gone through a lot of trauma
therapy for that specific event but then
sort of that continued just
as i graduated and went to college
of just
thinking that like i'm only good for
like my body and my looks and like i
have to i'm here to like sort of i don't
say serve like men but like letting
them like just do whatever
they want to me and so i had same with
college i i went to a year um at a
university of palestine university and
um
that was that was definitely what uh
messed me up a lot of just it was a very
it's the number one like party school
and
i would just
get like black out drunk with like my
friends and stuff because we'd go to
parties and stuff but i was doing it
sort of like a
okay i'm gonna get blackout drunk so
that when i have sex with guys later i'm
not gonna remember it um and that would
just be sort of like what i would
do in that
and
that went on throughout like the whole
year and
also at this point i should mention that
i
i
i always like love my body like because
i just thought like oh i'm you know
i'm very just like i was very like
healthy and stuff like i you know very
like curvy and stuff i i was very just i
loved my body and like who i was i was
very like happy with who i was and
then
i
after drinking like so much and stuff
which that definitely that made me gain
weight um by the end of the year
and
i gained about like 10 pounds or so i
was still like you know i was like 130
or something as so i wasn't like really
over i wasn't overweight or anything but
that sort of like
triggered something in my brain of like
oh
like i need to just like lose a little
bit of weight and
that's
how it started of just like
oh like guys like i need to because i
also like met a girl that was a lot
skinnier than me and so i and she got
like a lot of like guys and stuff and i
was like super just like oh i want to be
her
and so i
was like okay i'm gonna like lose just
like five pounds or so to get back to
ten five ten pounds to get back to like
my weight that i'm normally at okay so
competition is a big part of all this oh
yeah
that competition is and then the social
media
exactly that's just feeds into it
exactly that so it that definitely
turned into
once i lost like the 10 pounds or
whatever it was i'm like oh this is a
little bit easy i'm kind of good at this
and i've never been like good at
anything in my whole life so
i was like okay like let's lose like a
little bit more and stuff in it
and it's also just it's like addicting
it's definitely you know
it's an addiction and
that just sort of
it turned into like oh as i'm losing
weight like oh i really like i need to
keep losing weight like how am i going
to do this like because at a certain
point when you
are
losing weight at first and stuff you
lose it pretty fast and then when you
get to a certain way that it you know
slows down a little bit so i
was kind of frustrated with how it
slowed down so i was like okay i'm gonna
you know i'm gonna like start doing coke
to like lose weight more because i also
i did drugs like casually like
throughout high school and like college
but very just like recreational not like
like it was a problem or anything and um
and so i
started
doing coke pretty often like
every day kind of for a little bit and i
wouldn't even get like high or anything
from it because i i've pretty i've adhd
so i don't know if that likes part of it
that i don't stimulants don't really
have like an effect on me necessarily i
just feel normal but i knew that it was
making me lose weight so i kept doing it
and
eventually that sort of led to
oh i can't really sleep so i'm gonna
like okay i'll start doing xanax and
stuff and that
that was my
that
was where i got
hooked for sure and that i was just i
started doing
xanax pretty often like every night sort
of not even it wasn't even about like
oh i'm doing this to lose weight now it
was about like i'm doing this so i can
silence all the thoughts in my head of
like
thinking about food and just my weight
24 7.
and
so i started doing a bunch of i started
doing xanax and i that one led to doing
ketamine every night and every day and i
i wasn't even like conscious of like my
body really at this time because i was
so just like
high all the time and i was getting like
in trouble with my parents all like and
then this was also like when quarantine
happened and
um and so i just the unemployment
getting unemployment money i was just
doing like drugs just
spending so much money on them and i
then sort of
everyone kind of like sort of was like
okay you're really skinny like
but you're kind of like making me
realize like oh you're really skinny and
next thing i knew i was
i lost like 40 pounds about 40 pounds i
i was 82 pounds um yeah what do you know
82. i'm 32 right now yeah i'm back there
yeah and so i like freaked out and so i
was like okay yeah like i'm gonna go to
treatment and so i went to treatment to
residential
five days in i
they gave i
because in eating disorder treatment
they don't let you go to the like close
the door when you go to the bathroom at
least like in residential because
obviously they're you know don't want
you to purge um so they watch you like
go to the bathroom like like okay i
don't i can't like go to the bathroom
while someone's like watching me so then
they gave me a laxative um any eating
disorder treatment which apparently i am
severely allergic to i went to
anaphylactic shock and
um i was like okay i'm gonna leave
treatment um so i left treatment and
then a couple months later i went to
like a php
and
i would like weight restored and but it
it was just like okay i weight restored
but
my my like my mind is not changed like
mentally i'm still like
wanting to like lose weight the minute i
like put on
the weight to get back to like the
minute i weight restored which was like
about like 105 um for my height which
i'm 5'4
um
i was like oh my god like i freaked out
and i sort of just like
went back into like the mindset of the
eating disorder and i because i also was
like once i got sober a little bit for
this and so i started like doing drugs
again you thought you were too heavy
yeah
yeah yeah and i i just thought that i
was like
so just like fat and just huge and stuff
so i started
just losing weight again more and
doing drugs more and
uh i never really dabbled in like
opioids or anything but the one time i
did
it turned out to be fentanyl and i
accidentally overdosed on fentanyl um
and
my i
i owe like my whole life to my cat
cowboy because she found me
lying on my back um in my room like
choking on my vomit and
she
um
she went and she like ran to my parents
room and she like jumped on my mom's
chest um and my mom like woke up and she
just had like a sixth sense like mom
intuition like your cat did this yeah my
cowboy and um
yeah so i i fostered during quarantine i
fostered six kittens and their mom all
by myself well my mom helped too but i
took care of them your cat yeah and i
had your mom that you were dean yeah
yeah exactly yeah and she yeah so i i
have always had this very special
connection with cowboy because i i ended
up adopting her and her mom effie um and
so i've raised her my whole life
not my whole life
every her whole life and so yeah she
found me um
and
it they when they took me to the er and
they gave me like narcan obviously and i
i
i remember also when they
they i was like kept falling back asleep
when they i was in the hospital and my
breathing was like going back down so
they were trying to like wake me up and
stuff and i like asked them i'm like
could i like because i was prescribed
i'm prescribed adderall which i've never
i've like abused or anything
surprisingly um
and i like asked him i was like oh can i
just like take my can i take my adderall
to like wake up a little bit not really
because i didn't realize that i was like
overdosing and
then i i
did realize but they told me that if
there was just a couple minutes later
um i would have died um
so i really i owe like
she cowboy like literally saved my life
your cat saved your life she did and i
love that cat so much she's a black cat
she's perfect um
and
so i
you would think that like accidentally
overdosing would be sort of like a
little bit wake up call like okay like
like maybe i shouldn't do this and so i
got like sober for a little bit and then
i
as the sort of
oh need to like lose weight came back
it was drugs started getting like really
bad again because that was always like i
was only really abusing drugs
because i just wanted to lose weight or
i just wanted to silence the things not
not realizing how much damage i was
putting my body through like at that
like
low of a weight and just doing like
i was doing like a academy in a day like
like taking like
nine milligrams of like xanax every
night just like putting my body through
so much stress
all because
i just wanted to like lose weight and
that's all that and the reason you want
to lose weight is to attract more men
you think it's well that's kind of what
i don't think that attract a man that's
i
i looking back on it and it's weird
because now i it definitely sort of just
transformed of like
needing to oh it went from leading to
like male validation to like
oh
needing like my own validation because
i knew that like guys aren't really
attracted to necessarily to like a very
underweight body you know and
but in my mind i was like this is what's
attractive like i don't even care about
like how the guys look at me like i need
to
care like i just want to like be happy
with myself and that's only i'm only
gonna be happy with myself if i'm you
know
severely underweight and i also think
part of it was that i was so
i just wanted to like shrink myself
because i thought that if i would shrunk
myself and that i
um
i would just have like a more
undesirable body that i wouldn't get
taken advantage of at this point so i i
think that that had
has a lot to do with just wanting to
just shrink myself and
um
anyways just i flash forward i
i um in 2021 i
i ended up
uh having say i went through xanax
withdrawals i had seven seizures
and part of that was also malnutrition
related and so i was in the hospital for
a week and i went to rehab
um and then i was after i got out of
rehab i was sober for like seven months
and this is just very recently in like
uh 2021 and i was like talking with this
guy and i really liked him we were like
had like a situationship for like three
months and so we weren't
dating but we were doing all the things
that couples do but he was still like
talking to his ex and i knew it but i
was just like oh it's okay like you know
he'll choose me eventually um
didn't end up choosing me um and so that
and i was like i was weight restored i
didn't really i was wanted to lose
weight still but it was just like i felt
generally like happy so it wasn't like
my priority necessarily it was always in
the back of my mind but when that
happened it was like oh okay time to
like do what i feel like what's making
me comfortable is like going back to
like losing the weight and stuff and
then i started i joined like online like
sort of eating disorder like communities
specifically on like twitter
and
in that just come in that can like
community is
that definitely has done like a number
on me because now i'm like oh
i'm getting i need validation from other
other people with eating disorders like
because
they're
it's just it's so like weird to so like
it just doesn't make any sense but
it
the competitive aspect of it it's like
because it's like who's who's gonna win
like when you know because it's either
you recover or you die really
um and
so i would i
post like
body checks that's what like i mean the
main thing i body checked probably like
30 times a day it's it's
it's really bad and so i'd start posting
body checks and like as i'm like losing
weight i'd get more like you know
attention from like other people with
eating disorders and like oh i'm getting
because it's like one thing for like
someone without an eating disorder like
probably like looks at like me or like
anyone you know with this weight and
just think like oh wow they're like
really skinny and like that you know my
dad always
makes sort of comments of like he
doesn't really
like want to like look at me because it
i mean he doesn't like say it like that
but it just it makes him so like sad and
stuff um and but to me
i like look at my i still look at myself
and i don't think i'm like skinny um and
so getting that sort of like oh other
people with how difficult is it for you
to maintain this weight are you using
drugs um right now i'm not using drugs
well i had like a relapse um like
like a couple weeks ago of just like i
did like i got with just with ketamine
and
i did xanax like once you you can
maintain this weight without much effort
or yeah at this point or are you purging
and doing things like that no i've never
purged um i've always i've never been
able to which is probably a good thing
because do you eat very little yeah so i
um
i would say on average i eat like
probably like
five to six hundred calories calories a
day yeah and i never really i've never
exercised besides like when i sports in
high school and stuff but with the
eating disorder i sort of just like kind
of cheated in my way to like losing
weight of like oh i'm gonna do drugs
because like that suppressed my appetite
but i at the certain point i like
i
got to like oh i can do this like sober
too of like not eating because
when you're my like i
think about
constantly like what all i think about
is
food all day of like when is the next
time i'm gonna eat like what am i gonna
eat um when i'm at work like thinking
about like how am i
how do i look like how's my body look to
other like people right now like to
other people i think i'm skinny it's
just it's genuinely like all
i think about it's all that's on my mind
ever and it's
it's really changed like
i've sort of become just like a
shell of a person in a way like of who i
used to be like i'd i've
isolated everyone because that besides
the other eating disorder people that i
was like friends with on the internet
and i don't really have any like friends
now and
it's just become that is like my number
one priority and i don't ever know how
i'll
sort of snap out of that of how
because there's nothing like and i'm
like completely self-aware like oh i
could definitely die like at this point
i have you understand the problem inside
and out it sounds like yeah i'm yeah i
understand the problem and i have like
already have health issues from it i'm
like pre-osteoporosis at 21 years old
and i have had um
i've just recently two have been like a
ton of hair loss which has been very
hard for me um i used to have really big
like thick full hair and i've
really thinned out um and even like that
like knowing that of like vitamin d
deficient anemic um
i'm just like oh it's fine like it's not
gonna happen to me like i'm not gonna
die or like and i think like oh there's
people with eating disorders that are
like 30 or 40 so like i can do this i
can do this at my age and i'll i'll
recover in like a little bit i'm just
going to give it a like a little bit
more time
but it it never goes away
do you think there's a solution to your
problem it's your mindset clearly yeah i
mean i know that there is like a
solution it's just
the fear of gaining weight is more than
honestly i'd rather
it's horrible to say but like i'd rather
die like skinny than
then
gain weight which is like and i don't
know how i'll like get myself when you
were when you were 105 pounds you felt
yeah i still like i look at that and i
think i was like huge
anything like even like i look at myself
when i was like
in the 90s and i just think i look like
like
huge like how like how did i like at the
time i like thought i was like oh kind
of skinny but now that i'm skinnier
looking at that i'm like oh like i'd
never want to look like that
are you happy right now
yeah happy in a way
it's
that's the thing is like losing weight
and like being skinny is like i think
that that is the only that and cowboy
are like the only things that i think
make me happy but i know that it's like
artificial it's not actual happiness
it's just happiness from
getting that validation of like
people like online
and
just feeling like
i'm just getting validation of like that
i'm killing myself almost in a way and
it's but to me it's like that i found
like the one thing that i'm like good at
good at and so i'm gonna like stick with
it and i just i don't know how i'll ever
like
i've been to i've been to multiple
treatment centers and i nothing has ever
changed my mindset of like
accepting weight gain like no matter
what and
i don't know like what
is going to change that i don't know how
i'm going to like ever
get out of it and especially because
eating because eating disorders
typically are more prevalent like people
develop them in like early teens
um
but i i developed it at 19 and so i'm
like okay well i'm sort of a late
bloomer and i'm going to have you know
people already i'm i know people that
i've had it for like 10 years already so
you know i'm just i'm going to have this
forever and that's and you do have it
you know forever in a way it doesn't
ever go away like the thoughts you just
sort of learn how to manage it from what
i'm told in treatment and that just
gives me no hope of like well i'm gonna
be stuck like this for the rest of my
life so i may as well just
you know
be
skinny because that's all that makes me
happy
and
it's just it started to it's definitely
now recently as it got
worse because now that i'm like have
been in this sort of community which
i've had
five twitter accounts get banned so i
don't have a twitter account at the
moment but um
because because it you put promoting
self that's what they say promoting self
harm because there's a whole yeah
there's a whole community because you're
so so thin yeah so like posting it and
like posting like body checks and so
they definitely like you know get rid of
accounts like that or because i i also i
i have a pretty big
following on tick tock like a hundred
thousand followers and
i even though i don't do i don't do
anything i just post like my outfits but
it that has turned into a lot of
you know looking at my body and it's
that's i know that that's why a lot of
people follow me and i know that it's a
lot of girls
following me because i'm skinny and that
it does it makes me a little bit sad in
a way because i i don't i know that
people are like looking at that and like
using that as sort of it's called thin
spo of like a reason to like want to
like you know lose weight and that
definitely makes me a little bit
uncomfortable to think about like
you know younger girls and stuff looking
at
me and thinking that that they want to
look like me but
even just like that i'm like okay that's
not even enough to like make me
want to like
you know change and
but um
but yeah like now that i'm i've so like
immersed in like the
community and the culture in a way like
um i literally like i have i wear this
red bracelet that i've wore
for like months now and this is like
a significant thing in the eating
disorder community to like show like oh
like other people with a need to sort of
like wear red red bracelet and stuff if
you you know i've never seen anybody in
real life with it but it's just so like
i i have made it my gen like my identity
like this is who i am
this is like
you know what i'm going to be for the
rest of my life is just like you know
i'm going to be
you know known my legacy is going to be
you know an anorexic i guess or
i don't know and
it
so i'm now it's even more so i'm so just
like
it has just consumed my mind and has
such a like grip on me that
it's made it so much harder to to even
begin to want to like
accept weight gain or anything like i
had gained a little bit of weight
like a couple weeks ago um like i was
like 88 or something and i like freaked
out and i
like went back to that's when i relapsed
with the ketamine and i
just went back to do that even though i
know that
the drugs and stuff is definitely like
put i'm not gonna say ruined but it's
definitely affected my
relationship with my parents because
i've i've always had a really good
relationship with them and i live with
them still
so they've
it definitely affects them and makes
them sad seeing that they can't do
anything because i'm an adult and they
can't force me into treatment or
anything like that and you know they
just feel like sort of hopeless but
i just even that like thinking about how
sad i my parents are and stuff and how
and i think also just like i don't want
cow i don't want to die and like leave
cowboy by herself what do you think the
core of it all is though i don't know
like that's the thing is like i don't
know and it's like
i don't know what
really just like
how it's like why this is happening to
me because
i feel just so like it's my own
like fault because i had a good
childhood i've always had good parents
you know very supportive i've i've never
had any like necessarily like abuse like
in that sort of sense and so i'm like
why is it why am i so like
[ __ ] up like in a way like why how did
i end up like this and
it just kind of frustrates me because i
don't
know and
so then i just think that i'm never
nothing's ever gonna get better because
i don't know
and
um
and even like yeah i'm like i'm in
therapy right now and it still is just
like not
better because i if you're not like in
that mindset to sort of accept
weight gain it's you're never gonna like
recover because you have that's like the
first step i mean recovery is for sure
possible but
for me it's just like oh it's possible
but it's not possible for me so and even
though i know it is and
i don't i just i don't yeah i don't know
what the core of it is and i don't
um
because yeah it's i mean it started out
with sort of like the male validation
but now it's definitely turned into
i think control definitely has a big
aspect of it because i just feel like
i've never i've never had control of
like my own body in a sense
because i've always just sort of like
let other people let other guys have
control of it
so
this is like for me like a way for me to
control it like i can control how i look
and what i eat and i can't control
anything else in my life because
you know i
you know i i my parents have like a lot
of control on me in the sense because
they for good reason you know i've
lied to them done a lot of bad stuff my
drug use has caused me to do a lot of
bad stuff like specifically with my
parents that i definitely
regret and so they have a lot of like
control on me in that sense of just
wanting
you know to make sure that i'm safe and
stuff and so i'm like okay this is the
only thing that i can control in my life
so i'm gonna keep you know doing it and
it
it's just yeah it's completely consumed
me and i feel like
i don't even
it's i've it's affected my work life for
sure i just had to put my two weeks in
on a job because i
i just i can't like i get so exhausted
and like fatigue like walking around and
stuff and i
i just i know i feel physically horrible
like all the time and
even that is like not enough to i'd i'm
like okay i'd rather feel like
physically horrible but be skinny then
you know have a happy you know life
doing stuff and going out with like
friends and stuff and be like okay like
a healthy weight not even
like you know
overweight like a healthy when that's
when my parents are like okay we just
please get like the literal like bare
minimum they've even tried to bargain
with me of like okay getting it's like
95 like or something even though that's
still underweight they're just like
trying to but i'm just like no i can't
like that's
i can't even imagine ever being like
back in the 90s or higher above than
that even though i
don't know how i'm gonna maintain you
know 82 pounds for the rest of my life
and that's what frustrates me the most
is
is just thinking like okay how am i
gonna
you know what thinking about like the
next day of like okay
what am i going to like die to cause
that thing so that goes in my head a lot
too is like
okay am i going to die because even
though i know that there's so many
people with eating disorders that are
you know
more emaciated and older and stuff but
i also have this component of you know i
put a ton of stress on my body with the
amount of drug use i've had and
you know that so i know that that
affects
even more so like risk of dying and
stuff and so that definitely goes on
throughout my head but it's
i just like don't care in a way and it's
like i'm suicidal like i don't want to
die but it's at the same time it's like
okay
i could die and i don't really
care necessarily like i don't want to
but i don't really care
um
and
yeah i don't know i don't like trying to
think back of like where what the core
of it is i honestly don't know like in
it
a lot of it could be just because i have
you know when yours have a restrictive
eating disorder or just restrictive diet
in general you get really
bad brain fog of just like
not really
you know
thinking of not knowing like i don't
have
i know i have thoughts i know i can say
i don't have thoughts but
i'm so consumed by just eating disorder
related thoughts or whatever that i just
i don't even think i i can't think of
like anything else or
really
carry up like it's given me a ton of
anxiety like i have really bad social
anxiety now talking with
people um and
it's i mean it's very like you know if i
would have done an interview
back in like high school when i was you
know at a healthy weight not restricting
my eating
probably would have been
you know
talking a little bit more more
i don't know how to explain it just not
you know
anxious and stuff like that but it's are
you certainly intelligent enough to
figure this out you're beautiful as
either way yeah i'm sure if you were
heavier or skinnier you'd be still
beautiful thank you and that's another
thing it's like with the intelligence
that i've never
i've never thought i was smart or
anything like that i've never been yeah
like i've never been good at anything
like i played sports never been like
really it's almost like your self-image
is the
yeah that is the issue here you for sure
and that can change over time yeah as
you get older yeah yeah it's just but in
a way it's like i don't i want it to
change but
i also like don't want like i want to
get better but like i don't know right
now at 21 you don't but yeah 27 you
might yeah and i hope that you know that
is the case and
i
i i just i don't think that i can't like
picture myself ever being
better in a way because i've always just
sort of had these
you know in a different forms of
self-harming throughout my whole life
like you know
letting guys have sex with me all
throughout high school and then now with
like the eating disorder is definitely a
huge thing of self-harm and i've also
you know actually physically self-harm
too and they're cutting yeah that's some
i've i'm not too
often but definitely like a cause i also
have i have borderline personality
disorder
and
that is uh
definitely a big source of my
impulsivity of um with the drug use and
i've really been like
not good with money it's definitely like
addicted to like shopping too and stuff
and just
it um
so yeah like the self-harm and um
and
um
seeing like that's something i like
start talking about stuff and i like
just completely forget what i'm saying
because i just have such bad brain fog
um
it's all right
yeah sophie thank you very much for the
interesting time thank you you're
fascinating thank you it's a stubborn
problem for a lot of people yeah it
definitely it takes so many some people
are overweight some people are
underweight and yeah and that's some
people are fine waiting they have a
problem right yeah and that's the thing
the people there's definitely a
stigma i guess when people think of like
just the average person thinks of like
the word anorexia you know they probably
have this image of like a really
emaciated like super like you know
unhealthy severely i've seen much
skinnier girls yeah exactly yeah exactly
and um
and
it's but actually the most
the
most like
not popular but
common eating disorder is binge eating
disorder um and
that
in only
i think
four or six percent or there's some like
12 it's a really low number percent of
people with eating disorders are
actually underweight um because it's
you know binge eating disorders is more
common um
and so i think that people just
you know think that also just should be
like a common rules that people just
shouldn't comment on other people's
bodies in general um whether you're
overweight underweight
and whatever just people should not make
any comments on it because that
definitely like
comments people have made
specifically this one thing that
if i could
give advice to anybody of like what not
to say to someone with an eating
disorder is
because when i like weight restored
if people would say i looked healthier
that would just be like the end like
that would i
look at the word healthier and like fat
so like that you know
saying that you know you can't say
anything about a woman's weight i've
learned exactly no yes um yeah my
parents are like walking around
eggshells with me like constantly
because it's it's just so
even like the smallest thing of like
of just like you think because it's so
competitive and like even like the
comment that you just made of like oh
i've seen girls much skinnier than me
i'm like or skinnier than me that's
i mean nothing i knew that you know he
didn't mean any harm by it but even
stuff like that i'm like okay
everything you say can be yeah it just
it everything can just be translated it
makes no sense to average people because
they're like
you know i didn't mean to like harm by
that you know i was saying that as a you
know it's a good thing in a way of like
you know you're healthier and surf or
whatever but it's
it's so just like you want to be sick
like i
want
to be sick and like unhealthy and just
sort of it definitely is an intention
thing too in a way of like
but i know it's like negative attention
but that's also just another thing just
wanting you know attention throughout my
whole life very very interesting talk
yeah
thank you thank you very much and good
luck thank you
you